foreign
exactly 12 years ago in a tedx talk I've
introduced my seven species of robot
a unique three-leg robot called Strider
a wheel leg hybrid were what called
impasse an amoeba robot and many more
now 12 years is a pretty long time
especially in a Cutting Edge field like
robotics how have our robots evolved
during the past 12 years what new
species of robot have you built since
then
hello my name is denisong and today I
would like to show you our next seven
species of robot
since my last tedx talk we've been
focusing on the development of humanoid
robots robots that look like us two legs
torso two arms and a head let me show
you some of the human robots that we
developed at our lab romella
Darwin is a miniature human a robot for
research and education that we made it
fully open source
Charlie is considered the United States
very first a full-size human a robot
throw RDS for a disaster relief
applications and shipboard autonomous
firefighting robot Sapphire and Thor
which uses this unique biologically
inspired actuator and many more I think
we build more than dozen different type
of human ear robots however
after more than a decade of human Aid
robotics research I'm starting to have
different thoughts now humanoids are
important and they're great however they
always fall down they're too unstable
and they're painfully slow yes these
they were trying to develop technology
that resolve these two problems but
still they are too expensive and they're
too complicated and most importantly
they're too dangerous you do not want to
be next to these big heavy moving robots
it might fall on top of you so what do
we do
foreign
now why is it so difficult to make
robots walk with two feet I mean we do
it all the time so once I wanted to
throw away everything I know about
robotics for a moment and try to think
fundamentally why is it so difficult to
make robots block with two feet and have
found something fascinating so check
this out
now when your robot tried to move
forward one of the reasons why
constantly falls down is because the
distance between your left and right leg
because your legs move forward and
backward up and down it creates this
unwanted twisting forces we call this
moments right now this is a video called
a robo one competition it's a robot
fighting competition and people who
participate in this combination are
robot hobbyists and if you look at the
robots they did involved it's brilliant
it's fast it's Nimble and it doesn't
fall down and if you look carefully they
always walk sideways
because if you walk sideways your left
and right leg line up so you're twisting
moments disappear I actually got this
inspiration by watching sports fencing
or belay that always walk sideways and I
think this is the reason why now one of
the problems of trying to make robots
move sideways is you cannot really use
your knees so what do we do
we rotate our legs it looks kind of
awkward right so actually let's change
the entire torso like this and make it
Walk This Way now the problem of this
kind of configuration is that you really
cannot use your feet and Ankle so what
do we do we get rid of them now let's
make more changes let's change the shin
and while doing that let's change the
head and something strange starts to
emerge
this is Nadi non-anthropovic biped in
other words it's a robot with two legs
but it does not look like a human how
does it walk it walks like this simple
fast easy low cost this is great now I
briefly mentioned about a robot called
Sapphire shipboard autonomous fire
fighting robot that we built this is a
robot for Navy ships and I don't know if
you've been on a Navy ship but if you
open this door it has a really high door
seals we call that knee knockers before
we had these robots it was very
difficult for the robot to climb over it
but if your robot does not have to be
like human we can do something like this
make the knee rotate at 360 Degrees
brilliant isn't this cool yeah
our robots can climb stairs but it's
rather difficult but now we can climb
stairs like this
now is this just simulation and
animation no in two weeks from the idea
analysis design and Fabrication in two
weeks we build our first robot and you
have not seen anything like this
you're wild and you use many different
type of tricks for example use it
utilize the sprayiness of the feet we
can store the energy and make it hop and
jump
one
[Music]
when we first introduced Nadi to the
community we had a pretty good impact in
the committee however this robot is
great for walking forward and backward
but how does it change directions it
can't
so we decided to work on the next
version called Sapphire uh Alfred Alfred
stands for autonomous leg personal
helper a robot with enhanced Dynamics so
think of this robot as two navies uh
stacked onto each other so it looks like
this so This robot is acts asymmetric
which means that there's no four
backwards or sideways now when it walks
it has a very wide stance right so it
can walk like this and this is great for
unstructured outdoor environments
however it's pretty slow if you want to
make it go really fast you can change
your body configuration and if you go
like this you can have your four legs
and backward legs and then you can
Gallop like a horse
there you go
and when you lift two of the arms you
can walk like Nabi then the two of the
other legs can be used as arms to pick
up boxes or press buttons and we're
pretty excited about this new type of
configuration we call this multimodal
Locomotion and this is Alfred
now while developing these robots we've
been also working on this new type of
act Trader now when we say act Traders
we're talking about these devices that
make the robot smooth just like muscles
and humans now most of the roles that
exist today electric robots use electric
motors with gears right and these are
really strong they're precise they're
good for manufacturing but for legs we
need something different we need
something like biological muscles that's
compliant spring and not only the
position but also change the force and
we developed a new type of actuator
called the Bayer act Trader Now using
this bare act Trader with the Nabi we
developed a second version called Nabi
2. now if you remember Nabi was our
experiment for uh studying new type of
bipedal locomotion but it turns out that
this knobby with these new actuators it
doesn't work very well in terms of
walking however unexpectedly we didn't
know this but this robot is great for
jumping and hopping you can jump forward
backward and turn directions it's
brilliant but the really cool thing is
once it jumps and when it lands the
motors become generators and the impact
is changed to electricity and it can
charge its battery so it's very energy
efficient
laughs
and 92 is ready to go
[Music]
or not
but this is knobby too so bear actuator
with Nabi was Nabi too then bear at
Trader with Alfred is Alfred two and
this is the next generation of the
Alfred so this is the very first time
you turn on the switch look carefully
the reaction of our students
foreign
excuse me
[Music]
I think it jumped about 1.4 meters this
is remarkable walking is also very fast
and stable
[Laughter]
[Music]
so he wanted to do something more
interesting want to make it do Taekwondo
[Music]
we're just having too much fun and
Alfred 2 is ready to go
[Music]
foreign
practical robot for example this is an
example of picking up a box delivering
it and putting nicely on the ground or
on the table I uh sped up the video
becomes pretty slow but you can get an
idea how we can use these type of new
type of robots for different
applications and this is Alfred two now
we looked at two legs we looked at four
legs what about six legs of course we
have a hexapod robot now this robot hex
is about the size of a small car now the
cool thing about six leg robots is this
now to have static stability the minimum
number of contacts with the ground is
three think of a camera tripod if you
have a hexapod robot you can always have
three point contact with the ground
three three and this makes it really
great for outdoor environment a rough
environment this particular robot we're
developing for D mining applications
getting rid of line mines Underground
autonomously
if you see it in person it's kind of
scary it's big and it goes like this
so this is hex we also have a smaller
version this is called Sylvia six leg
vehicle with intelligent articulation
and as I mentioned these type of rollers
are really great for unstructured train
such as this
you can also climb up and down stairs
and this robot might be the strongest
six leg robots out there 20 kilograms
ah
now the reason why you wanted to make it
really strong is because you want this
robot to do some very interesting new
type of stuff
so this is the very first robot that can
brace between walls and climb up so it's
like Spider-Man Isn't that cool
and it has some other tricks too if you
put suction cups on the feet it can
stick to the wall and climb
and if you give it an arm it can do some
fun stuff on the Blackboard too
and this is Sylvia so we talked about
the vertical mobility 12 years ago in my
last tedx talk I've introduced a robot
called climber it's a robot for climbing
Cliffs using cables like a human but
this year we want to get rid of the
cable we want to make it do free
climbing and I'm very excited to
introduce a brand new robot called
scalar spine enhance climbing autonomous
leg exploration robot now when you first
look at it it looks like a generic
portal pit robot four leg robot it's
actually very strong but strength is not
all we had to develop this new type of
gripper we call these spine grippers
that can really grab onto the surfaces
and this video we just took it a few
days ago so literally it's taking its
very first few steps now why are we
interested in Cliff climbing robots
rescue missions of course but we're
really interested in the planetary
applications now as you know in Mars we
have these Rovers discovering the new
planet however the really science Rich
site are always at the cliffs and these
Rovers cannot get there so something
like this will be enable those kind of
exploration in the science Rich sites on
planetary surfaces this is scalar now we
talked about legs but what about wheels
of course we have ROBLOX with wheels
this is called ombro omnidirectional
balancing unicycle robot and as the name
implies it has one wheel it's
omnidirectional it can go forward
backwards sideways and diagonal but if
you look at it it doesn't even need to
change its orientation when you see it
it's almost like magic it feels like
it's Gliding Over the surface Isn't that
cool it can also balance and climb very
steep surfaces
now it follows path is now yes it has
one wheel but actually has these smaller
rollers in the rim to generate this kind
of motion as well so why do you want to
build a robot like this we like to have
robots living with us in this
environment and in this world sometimes
just crowded a lot of people are
obstacles to uh go through people or do
uh uh avoid obstacles it's very
important to have a very small
cross-section and probably a single
wheel is the best way to have a very
small cross section and this is on bro
now I've shown you many different shapes
sizes mechanism robots and if you
remember this the whole thing started
because we had problems with this
bipedal locomotion is there a way to
make these humanoid robots not fall at
all
there is and this robot is called
balloon
even by the way
what if robots never fail
[Music]
what if we could change the direction of
gravity I'm very excited to show you our
new robot Balu who is the assistant
lightweight leg unit this robot is a
five pillar robot size of a human being
but the body is a helium balloon it's a
balloon with two legs how does it walk
it walks like this
very elegant isn't it
this robot might be the safest robot out
there you can walk forward backwards
sideways can turn directions
yep we want this world to be living with
us so it can climb Upstairs Downstairs
go over obstacles
[Music]
it's fun to play with it and play with
it can hop now you can hop up to a
height of a tabletop
oh this robot is a good dancer if you
turn on the music it listens to beat and
it dances to be
[Music]
now we do crazy things when we do
experiments once we open the window and
threw the robot out the window
is it great it solves all the problem of
buy through Locomotion it's cheap it
doesn't fall down however it also
creates new problems this robot has
horrible Outdoors because if the wind
blows
it floats away
now these are some of the images of our
secret projects I'm not gonna explain it
but we're using projection mapping uh
Vortex counters of many different things
oh this robot literally can walk on
water you put ping pong balls on the
foot you can walk on water you can also
walk on a tightrope
it's cool this is Baloo
by the way all of our videos end with a
bang like this
is that cool this is Balu
thank you
[Applause]
now all of this new inventions and
creativity came from the problem of
human a robots however
secretly we've still been working on
human and robots and this robot is
called Artemis our latest one Advanced
robotics technology for Ines move and
improved stability and this is the very
first time you're showing to the general
public this is a sneak peek of what is
about to come now this road Artemis uses
new type of Technology it's based on
that bear actuator and because it's so
new you cannot buy any of these
components so I have to design and
fabricate every single part of this
robot
we have just finished assembly of the
lower body
and I'm very excited to show you a sneak
peek
of robot Artemis
[Music]
and Artemis is coming to I cannot wait
to show it to you probably on stage in
my next talk I've shown you a lot of our
U.S creation robots from our labrum
Milan I would like to give credit to our
brilliant hard-working students at
romilla but what is the source of this
creative creativity what's the source of
this energy what is the secret to this
crazy productivity I think the next
video will be able to answer that
question
you remember Baloo we're doing the
experiment of dancing by the way this is
Saturday 2 A.M in the morning
[Music]
foreign
so yeah let's bring out all our robots
one by one
[Music]
you mean remember Navi
day every night
a early prototype of Alfred
[Music]
his favorite Darwin Opie
the rotating knee mechanism for Dobby
[Music]
a pod robot
this is romella the Robotics and
mechanism laboratory at UCLA
by the way that's me on the left Dancing
you probably haven't seen a professor
dance and party where the students while
conducting serious experiments right
openness Freedom trust having fun and
truly believing what you do can change
the world these are some of the secrets
behind our next seven species of robot
thank you very much